o
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a boa noite goleadores e para a internet
já a vtex combina com acessibilidade
tanto para mães
eu sou amiga dias já mira de exemplo é
membro do grupo mão na roda para quem
não sabe mão na roda é um é um grupo
constituído por pessoas com deficiência
e fazemos das 100 cadeiras de roda e não
só também grupo está em pessoas ditas
normais a falar como é que entra como é
que eu entrei na mão na roda
vou falar um pouco do meu percurso até
chegar lá
tenho dez anos quando fui atropelada por
um responsável não tinha carta de
condução e na altura por não ter
condições médicas terá que postar aqui
em casa a ver quem fica se ele guarda
portugal a chegar a portugal
tive aqui durante uma semana ao chegar
lá é que o descobrir do fato que tinha
acontecido comigo naquele acidente
lembro exatamente do acidente mas não me
lembro o que aconteceu durante aquela
semana ninguém dizia nada e quando chega
a iná
quando cheguei no hospital primeiro é o
primeiro hospital que eu entrar e é que
eu descobri mas descobrir é descobrir eu
acabei por descobrir uma forma dolorosa
porque tinha dores depois ano como não
ligar porteiro dez anos não não ter um
membro rio com dez anos de mercado a dor
da boca para não ligar muito depois fui
durante um tempo fui detido entre até
mesmo durante vários meses e durante o
tempo a depois surgiu o uso da prótese
eu não sabia que ele existia a não sabia
que eu ia usar aquilo e
meu pão primeira vez o impacto com a
prótese foi dolorosa porque este gesto
lei isso é imenso
há ainda opção dizer que ainda estão em
fase de adaptação também por onça é
difícil quando se está em um objeto que
não é teu
no teu corpo e acaba por uma batalha do
time
depois e foi 95 ocidente foi 95 em 2009
já tinha já esperada já tinhas pra dan
aquela faz em 2009 é que se submeter a
uma nova cirurgia por foi feita uma
cirurgia errada na época e durante o
tempo durante julho de 2009 a dezembro
foi o impacto pra mim porque durante
aquela fácil ficar sem prótese e eu pra
quem me conhece sabe que eu tinha muito
preconceito
eu fui vítima do do meu preconceito
porque a maior parte dos meus amigos não
sabia que usava próteses porque eu tinha
licença
e naquela altura a isolar e muito
isolada porque deixa de usar próxima
durante aqueles meses de 2009 de 2009
islaine casa exceto irpaa após hospital
quando iam buscar ficava em casa quando
hoje quando os meus pais meus irmãos e
eu ficava em casa durante brom
já em 2000 e dezembro de 2009 que vata
consegue usar prótese e naquela altura
estava a entrar em depressão e está
naquela fase de opção e me ensinava
muita coisa coisa de quem tem vergonha
de estar a pronunciar-me muita coisa
campeã em felizmente passou pela minha
cabeça e seguimos em mim seguimos vir
passar
aqui só vencendo em passar o natal em
2001 e 2009 mas só que como já tinha
naquela altura estava a estudar o o
segundo ano da faculdade
como já tinha perdido ano se ele passar
dois meses aqui e quando você 2004 guga
sai portugal eu fui cuidar e que tinha
que mudar a minha vida não sabia o que
queria fazer porque o e o que eu ia
fazer e onde quem vai fazer o que eu
queria começar por cá ver outra vez
agora sai
já em final de agosto de 2000 e 2010
sobre sair pra ver e passando um ano em
são vicente sem fazer nada dava dinheiro
para ajudar o trabalho várias vezes fui
a entrevista de emprego infelizmente não
foi isso aí porque ainda temos aqui pra
sair
sou mulher tem decência então foi mais
difícil depois de um ano e eu não queria
dar o braço a torcer por portugal eu
disse vou tentar outra ilha e como não
tinha dinheiro para vir à praia que eu
fiz isso a agência
fui lá e falei com o elenco da agência
regular no barco vindo barco em 24 horas
um barco mas a minha vontade era era
explorar outra ilha era ver o que cansa
de ser e como é que vão dizer nada
acontece por acaso e chegando à quinta
numa sexta-feira quando o elemento do
grupo na roda e ela convida a entrar no
grupo
ela convidou segunda à tarde fui fui
deus nos sites mas quando falei não sai
mais ou menos um mês 43 jacot semana a
vê los nos ensaios
mas o preconceito era tanto porém com o
pessoas com deficiência dançar eu disse
uau
e mesmo sabendo que os quatros marcos
vilaça dançar eu não sabia o que eu
tinha
qual é multi deficiência não disse se o
governo em meu tipo de preconceito ea
primeira vez que eu via os dançarinos na
rua pedonal
eu meu sim foi dan foi logo logo em
seguida assim eu quero entrar no grupo
na hora mas eu escolhi roubar pra dançar
no grupo na roda que cícero flávio
neste momento eu flávio foi aos poucos
tirar do meu próprio site
eram os últimos ensaiar em setembro
esquecer os outros têm de ser portas
fechadas não tem ninguém poderia ver o
nosso ensaio e quando eu comecei quando
nós fizemos a coreografia disso já agora
tenta descobrir a porta desse naufrágio
eu entrei em pânico disse não espera
ainda não estou preparada em si não vai
ser agora eu não sou
aos poucos abrindo uma porta e surrou
existem alguns na roupa do nada e só
geram curiosa e eu sempre ver o nosso
site
aí comecei a a atirar aos poucos meu
preconceito
logo em seguida e foi isso templo e
novembro
fizemos um espetáculo meu primeiro
espetáculo na roda que eu entrar e choro
baba entre um espetáculo era assembléia
e se bastava saia e disse não acredito
vou deixar toda a gente vê
eu entrei em pânico pior ainda tem que
entrar na no pago que irá prótese as
pessoas verem então que foi pra mim e
depois que sai e no outro nos fizemos
respeitado num no outro dia
sempre ficamos à espera dos das fotos do
espetáculo estava ver muitas
notificações das minhas fotos e disse
sim paraíba tem que ver o que se passa é
uma foto minha no facebook
daí eu cortei foto não fosse tirar e não
queria passar em várias vários dias e
disse não vou tirar vovô por lamine
cronologia já basta
hoje em dia uma piscina tomar banho no
mar
e como na roda tem uma roda fez por mim
durante esses cinco anos não encontra aí
felizmente encontrei em portugal
foi aqui que eu e vim encontrar vi me
libertar libertarem do do meu
preconceito
hoje em dia lembro a mídia falando
sempre do espetáculo meu espetáculo na
roda
as pessoas pediram a mira por cancelar o
espetáculo por provavelmente não está
ninguém na sala mas ela pela
persistência dela ela disse não se
formou no país a vale a pena já vai
valer a pena o esforço nós fizemos ainda
vai em tela foi assim
não foi assim porque acredito na roda
está em está em salvar muitas pessoas de
mesmo dentro do grupo e fora do grupo
que nos venha dançar a partir logo no
início de junho é o conceito que eu
tinha que as pessoas com deficiência o
décimo enquanto o nosso trabalho é é
gratificante e roda am em abril acabou
por abrir o cada um à sua maneira de
pensar
o único problema que nós enfrentamos
diariamente infelizmente isso não
depende de nós são os obstáculos isso
encontramos todos os dias
obstáculos quando igor sadino dixon
obstáculos e nos edifícios physics mas
sim a maneira de pensar deus por aí o
preconceito
graças a deus através da roda
eu gostaria que as pessoas também falar
num ela fez um trabalho lindo na praia
busca ligada possibilidade
ela pôs hoje do governo numa das rodas
pra ver quais seriam os obstáculos
encontrados diariamente
infelizmente foram presos
os minutos mas nós encontramos
obstáculos dias é no edifício é nos
supermercados nas mãos
acho eu tô eu acho que quando eu ando
letras mesmo colega cada roda
muitas vezes não conseguem entrar no
edifício desce desce diante do frio do
do serviço público porque não conseguem
entrar num serviço infelizmente eu
acredito que o trabalho traz em uma roda
tem feito até que já mudou já mudou
várias souza mudou há alguma maneira de
pensar e acredito que ainda temos indo
um caminho a percorrer até chegar lá e
dizer os termos de acessibilidade
agora quero apresentar vos uma dança em
cada roda com miriam dina presidente do
grupo numa roda fundador e presidente do
grupo na roda
[Aplausos]
[Música]
vou à por borboletas abril já sai voando
nem trazem que mora até quando levo o
[Música]
boca tem nenhum disse stern
mesmo disputando no rebanho a boca da
exist para quem voa boy abrigo já sair
vivo mesmos pirapó
[Música]
prender viva méxico
cada
[Música]
[Aplausos]
é uma mensagem pato tinto anda
sobreviver
tudo alguém sim força pávoa a viver na
nem de espanha
[Música]
na band
ei
afim ou já tá
[Música]
campinho já saimon
mesmo perdendo a bola ae
[Música]
no poder me ver
cada
[Música]
[Aplausos]